[music]
>> The next translation
is Dawatul Quran.
Again, this Dawatul Quran originally
from Arabic to
Urdu
done by Shams Pirzada, Maulana Shams
Pirzada.
And Maulana Shams Pirzada, may Allah
grant him Jannah, too.
And all the people who have done good
work including right from Abdul Aziz Ali
and Taqeeuddin Hilali.
All the people, alhamdulillah.
What he has done, he has done a
compilation of other tafasir. Though his
best tafsir is of Maududi.
His best tafsir is Maududi, but he tried
to improvise on it and refer to other
tafsir. He looked at many and then
written. This is This is amongst
the good tafsir.
Now, when we say translation, when we
say commentary, translation means
translating only the Quran.
Tafsir means giving a commentary. So,
Abdullah Yusuf Ali, as I said, has got
footnotes and
commentary. Now, this amongst
the English, if you want to read the
best translation and tafsir, and if you
have the time,
number one I would recommend is Tafsir
ibn Kathir.
Again, amongst the Arabic tafasir, the
two most popular and the most important
one is Tabari
and the other is ibn Kathir.
Tabari is more meant for the scholarly.
It is very voluminous.
And Tafsir ibn Kathir, both of them are
the two most important. There are
various other tafsir. Various. In
Arabic, there are many.
In our library, we have a section only
of Arabic tafsir.
There are many.
We are not going to discuss about
Arabic. But, only the two main one I'm
saying
are tafsir done by Tabari and by ibn
Kathir. Yes, Tabari has been translated
to English.
And ibn Kathir also has been translated
But,
when ibn Kathir did the thing, what he
did, he collected the various views of
different mufassirin.
The commentators. So, this verse of the
Quran
have 10 different views of 10 different
commentators, which is good for you to
know. So, if you read Tafsir ibn Kathir,
one commentary come to the views of
various other commentators.
But, the problem in Tafsir ibn Kathir is
he doesn't say which is correct, which
is wrong. Sometimes he gives his
opinion, "Okay, I agree with
tafsir of so-and-so person."
Sometimes he gives
and he leaves it.
So, now you as a guy should know many a
time when you are debating, your
opponent may say, "Tafsir ibn Kathir
says this." Blah, blah, blah. Khallas,
Tafsir ibn Kathir means a normal Muslim
who has little knowledge. Khallas.
If he quotes Tafsir ibn Kathir, it
doesn't mean it is correct, please. It
is the most popular tafsir. What Tafsir
ibn Kathir has done, he has compiled the
various views of different commentators,
which is good for you to know, but it
doesn't say it is authentic.
This translation person by Darussalam,
what they have done
that they have tried to remove the
unauthentic views.
So, this is a bridged version.
This is a bridged version of the Philip
McCaslin. It's in 10 volumes.
Done by Darussalam, headquarters in
Riyadh.
By Malik Mujahid.
Very good work.
Again, I cannot say all
Zaeef has been removed from here.
That also I mean done by human beings.
And if I'm not mistaken,
a Sheikh Safiur Rahman Mubarakpuri was
the head of the team if I'm not
mistaken.
I did it
years, decades.
So, done by Safiur Rahman Mubarakpuri,
this is a book I think should be there
in the next section.
So, Tafsir ibn Kathir is very good. If
you have the time, read, but
please don't get
a wrong information that if it's
mentioned here, ibn Kathir himself is
alhamdulillah. So, sometimes he gives
his opinion, okay, I believe in this,
but not always.
So, for you to have a knowledge of
various tafasir, it's very good.
But
everything may not be authentic.
It's good to know many things
if you are a student of knowledge.
So, it means you can identify what is
good and what is bad.
Not for a
layman per se.
So, that is the reason when someone
quotes ibn Kathir, that doesn't mean
yes.
Can be right also. And many times it is
right.
But when your opponent quotes
ibn Kathir,
it's not like Bukhari. Bukhari means
khalas.
So, that you have to be careful.
And many a time, what I'm talking about
the rules of understanding,
if you study in a particular university,
Every university has its own ideology of
understanding the Quran. And I know many
people are from different parts of the
world, and some of you are graduates
from Islamic University, etc.
For your information, I'm no graduate
from any Islamic University.
I'm not.
But alhamdulillah, I visited many
Islamic universities, interacted with
the heads and the top scholars. First
alu ahli zikri in kuntum la ta'lamun.
Therefore, I met many, masha Allah.
So, that's a very strong point.
The art is
that when you can grasp the 3-year
course
or maybe 1-year course in few days, by
speaking to the head is an art.
So, whenever I meet an expert,
whatever appointment I have, I leave it
aside and try and extract what I can.
I always say,
era banke pera khao. There's a saying in
Urdu, which is in the low language. Era
banke pera khao means
eat the good
delicacies
by behaving like a fool.
And get the best of it.
People try and be a hero,
and then become zero.
So, when you know you're meeting an
expert,
one thing is there.
Even if you realize there's a fault,
forget it. Now, you're not come for that
fault here.
So, when you identify he's an expert,
and suppose he makes a mistake, suppose,
hypothetically. Point number one, it may
not be a mistake because you are not up
to that level
to know what's a mistake, point number
one. Even if it is there,
hypothetically, okay, neglect it. Learn
what is good. People try and pick.
So, when I meet an expert, even if I
disagree, I say, "Okay, one point, I'll
keep it aside. The balance 99 points at
least I'll gain." So, when I go on
talking about that one point, what do I
do?
I'm losing the benefit.
First alu ahli zikri in kuntum la
ta'lamun.
If you don't know, ask the person
knowledgeable. And I remember in the
first hour training program, I was much,
I mean, I was young that time. Now also
I'm young, masha Allah.
That time I was about 34, 35 years
young.
And now I'm 50 years young, mashallah.
I'm made young.
Young in heart, young in body,
alhamdulillah.
And may Allah always keep me young.
But I remember
at that time there were many of the
students, you know, I was 30 years and
some 40, some 50, some graduate, some
postgraduate from Islamic University of
Medina and all. So, first 2 3 days, they
were doing testing with me. You know,
testing?
Testing me, they let's see, you know,
what is this person, you know, we have a
graduate and this person. Fine, he's
famous.
Not that.
But in the first 2 days,
alhamdulillah, they realized they said,
"Sorry, you know, we were
So, the first thing is when you meet an
expert and when you realize he's an
expert, try and get the best from him.
Rather than trying to prove you're a
hero.
And that time, what happened, there was
even a Malaysian.
You know why there were 19 people last
time? One person was extra smart. I told
him to leave.
Was from Malaysia. You know, breaking
the rules of Quran and Sunnah. You come
here to break the rules of Quran and
Sunnah?
You are coming to be a die.
Fine, you can ask a question,
but trying to misguide the people. So,
in such a situation, I'm very tough. Let
a small loss take me to prevent a big
loss. So, when I come to know any one
student is trying to create mischief,
which will cause loss to the other
students, I tell him pack up.
I'll even pay for his ticket. I said,
"You don't need a ticket. You take your
ticket money and get out."
So, when you meet an expert, number one
is try and gain from him.
What people think, "Expert and I'm also
going to tell him I'm more expert than
him."
So, there's a saying,
you try and become a hero and you'll end
up becoming a zero.
When you meet an expert, behave like an
average man
and gain the knowledge.
Out of 100 points, you disagree with one
point, okay, don't follow it.
Correct? Put it in the dustbin. At least
gain the 99. Not to prove his 1.0 is
wrong, you keep on debating and you
lose.
And all the other people benefit.
Every man has got faults.
Including myself.
But this is an art.
How to extract the best
when you meet an expert.
That's very important. As we were
discussing
from the tafsir
that this is the Noble Quran which is in
nine volumes.
And there are many as tafsirs. Amongst
the best voluminous tafsir in English is
Tafsir ibn Kathir, but take the one
printed from Dar-us-Salam which is
abridged, which has removed most, if not
all, of the unauthentic sources.
Not all, yet there are.
So, when anyone says this tafsir is from
authentic sources, yes, alhamdulillah.
But a human being can make a mistake.
But as a whole, yes.
You can rely on most of the things. If
you read the abridged version, and if it
gives a commentary, that commentary
which is matching with the Quran has
been kept. That which goes against the
Quran and sahih hadith has been removed.
But again, it's done by a group of
scholars, [snorts] research scholars,
which can make mistakes. There are yet
some hadith etc. which are
based on da'if etc. But as a whole, it's
good, alhamdulillah. This is Noble Quran
again by Taqiyuddin al-Hilali and
Dr. Muhsin Khan,
which is also good if you have the time.
I've just scratched the surface.
This is one more tafsir, Ishaq
al-Mawardi.
Coming to tafsirs.
It is voluminous, I think in 14 volumes.
This is by Sayyid [snorts] Abul A'la
Maududi. He has picked up tafsir of
Tabari
and ibn Kathir, Maududi, and where he
felt this is much better than the
others, not reach the level of ibn
Kathir. So, there are many other people
who came and said, "Okay, fine. Ibn
Kathir has done a know job. I'll try and
I may disagree with this. Okay, it's
fine, but this is better.
So, there are the same.
So, this
is a good one written recently. It's
done by Almani done by Said Iqbal. Said
again an Indian.
I think when I met him I think he was in
the mommy if I'm not mistaken.
I have only mentioned 10
in the list. There are
around there are many I can name if you
want. Everything is there. Zidane is
there, but I don't the name because this
is just I've selected a few. There are
many translation. Each one has its pros.
Each one has its cons. Their translation
only by again I don't want to name only
scientific only scientific work seems to
be good. I read it.
I don't want to name the translator.
It's always good to speak good about
people other than the negative factor.
It is safe. If the negative is wrong
then we get the thing, but when I read
I don't agree with some of the
scientific points he mentioned.
Find it has a variety of every verse
he's trying to prove scientifically.
Good.
But
there are many. This is just
we are scratching the surface.
There may be an English language I don't
know may have reached about 90 to 100. I
think it may have crossed a century by
now.
In the library we have at least 70 80
if not more.
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]
>> All Rahman
All Rahman
All Wahab